let's talk about one of the most
powerful vitamins for healthy
skin well it's not vitamin e
or vitamin c these are very important
but what's even more important is
vitamin b3
and that is because if you are deficient
in vitamin b3
you could end up with a condition called
pellegra but there's also
a subclinical version of a b3 deficiency
which is not the full-blown
disease but
a condition where you have dermatitis
dry
brittle skin scaly skin red skin
even skin that is cracking is bleeding
so vitamin b3 is essential for
keeping your skin very very healthy at a
very deep level
it protects and restores your dna so it
actually goes very very deep
and vitamin b3 does a lot more than just
helping you with your skin helps
cholesterol
it can decrease the risk of
schizophrenia and depression
but in 1931 a chemist discovered if you
give
a patient with pellegra vitamin b3
they become cured it gets rid of their
pellegra
so that's when they connected the link
between pellegra being a vitamin b3
deficiency
and they found that people that had
pellegra were consuming
way too much corn or
flour refined flour or rice
or drinking too much alcohol so what
they did to solve this problem
at that time was instead of telling
people to avoid corn
flour and rice they enriched the grains
with synthetic version of vitamin b3 and
other
vitamins now if you've been watching my
videos for a while you're probably on
healthy keto you're doing intermittent
fasting
and you don't really have to worry about
this because you're not
consuming corn flour rice or
well alcohol maybe you are a little bit
but hopefully not too much and you've
probably noticed that your skin is
really great
but if you're new to my channel and
you're still consuming these foods
you may need some b3 i'm going to
recommend
you would take it in a niacinamide form
this is the one that doesn't give you
that red
flushing sensation vitamin b3 can also
help decrease the risk of the brown
spots on your skin
decrease risk of skin cancer it has
anti-aging factors for your skin
it can also help you decrease acne
and this is probably why a lot of these
skin creams
have this as one of the ingredient
now i found that you can get vitamin b3
in pretty much
any food that you eat so that's really
not the problem the problem is
consuming certain things that are
depleting
b3 so anyway i just wanted to make this
connection for you
in case you might be deficient in b3
this could be a simple
solution thanks for watching before you
go if you have a question about a
product
or you're new to keto and you want to
know how to begin
keto or you're on keto and you need a
debug because it's not going as smooth
i have a keto consultant standing by to
help you
this is just for the people in the us
hopefully in the future we'll be able to
answer everyone's call
but i put the number down below so you
can call
and get some help